calm on the streets of tunis
a stark contrast to days of protests
many have not dared to face the army and
security forces
which are now patrolling the streets and
tunisia's parliament
the country's biggest political group
the anata party has called for dialogue
and accused the president of a coup
we reject these unconstitutional
announcements uh and we
welcome all the rejections that have
come from
most other tunisian political parties as
well as civil society organizations
and we call on the tunisian people to
be calm and vigilant and be ready to
defend
their democracy
[Music]
many came to the streets in celebration
and outrage
at president kai saeed's bold move
firing the prime minister
and freezing the parliament for a month
president saeed says his decision was
taken after following the process laid
out
in the constitution nevertheless i have
taken responsibility
i am taking a historic responsibility
those who claim this matter is related
to a coup
need to revise their lessons in the
constitution
president saeed who controls the armed
forces made a stark warning against
anyone taking up arms saying the biggest
danger a nation can face
is internal explosion the dismissed
prime minister hishen mushishi says he
will not be a disruptive element
he will hand power to whoever the
president chooses
like the street like the tunisian street
the parliament is
also divided today between the majority
leading
parties in the parliament like nada
cartoons and
karama coalition who called and
described
the the decision of president kai side
as
a constitutional dictatorship who are
against his decisions tunisia's
democracy is leaving
its biggest test today there were also
fears of a crackdown on the freedom of
press
after security forces stormed al
jazeera's buildings
it's a move al jazeera has strongly
condemned
the president's move had followed mass
protests with much of the anger directed
at the anata party
for its handling of the economy and a
raging pandemic
others fear it's an unconstitutional
power grab
that could lead to a dictatorship a move
that would see the end to the jasmine
revolution
that paved the way to a decade of
democracy
laura burden manly al jazeera let's
cross over to muhammad vallar
correspondent who's covered
tunisia extensively for al jazeera
muhammad it seems that the
turnaround you might say by uh hanada
has is
been quite swift and quite surprising
yeah that's right so i think another has
realized that
the the conditions on the ground are not
in their favor or in the favor of their
call
for more demonstrations they have seen
those decrees
taken by the president yesterday and
they have seen the army
uh from you know ranging its stance
range
ranging from neutral to to pro president
the army ready to protect the um the
decisions and make
make sure they are implemented the army
has been guarding the
uh the government buildings and
preventing chaos from happening or
preventing confrontations
so those decisions were a strong message
from the president yesterday to the
people of tunisia and another party has
received us that message nada has a
history of uh
moderation as well in their in their
stances whenever there is a huge crisis
in tunisia
and probably that's one of the reasons
why tunisia has been able to avoid
um the fate of uh of egypt and other
kind of
other arab spring countries in 2013 2014
another gave major concessions
in order to make sure that the national
dialogue could reach a
national consensus or a reconciliation
they also in 2016 another decided to
to um to abandon its policy of
islamic proselytizing as a part of its
political ideology
and it reduced itself into a political
party so they have a history
of this kind of of moves to appease
whenever there is a an escalation and
now they have
done it again and but they are very
resilient apparently and they want to
continue the struggle
by any other means than violence they
have called for dialogue
national dialogue and they also they
have called upon their base
to remain vigilant and not to allow the
um
what they call the coup against the
constitution to uh to succeed
they are one of the largest political
parties but if they've turned you might
say
180 degrees to a certain extent do you
think other opposition parties and the
unions are all going to
fall into line and just be patient over
the next 30 days and see what happens
that's very likely so very likely
because anada is the spearhead of all of
this
of this contest with the president
the other parties also they know that a
huge chunk of the population
is pro pro pais
president rice they have seen
demonstrations in the streets and also
one of the
strongest and biggest movers and shakers
in politics in tunisia
is the the national union trade unions
and they have
met with the president their statement
after that meeting showed that they are
not against the decisions that have been
taken by president reiss so
just in the same manner the other
parties are not likely to decide
to escalate on their own muhammad thanks
very much
for that update muhammad well there for
us in doha let's join
nufa labud he's the executive director
and co-founder of the nordic center for
conflict transformation
joins me now from rabat via skype good
to have you with us
on the program it seems that opposition
parties and maybe the unions too
are between a rock and a hard play a
hard place they have
very little wiggle room at the moment
until this very vital 30 days is over
yes exactly what is different today in
tunisia is that
before uh before the establishment of
the democracy in in tunisia there was a
contestation between a social movement
and an authoritarian regime for decades
today there is a conversation still
between a social movement
but democratically elected institutions
uh we have to know also that tunisia
is still a young democracy is just have
been established
and they have done that and succeeded
that through
the national dialogue which tunisia are
very good at which won them actually the
nobel peace prize
of peace in 2015. i think the
yes no no i hadn't interrupted you at
all i was just wondering now then
uh that do and how important is it
that all of the um stakeholders
do sit down and talk and is there a
requirement
to have any extra mediation in there
from the eu
the un or another independent body
perhaps
yeah i think for now what is important
is that the decision for all the
political actions to sit together
that we are no longer within an
authoritarian regime in tunisia
but we are in democratic regime in
tunisia and everything has to happen
within that democratic process and
democratic
framework to do so it the importance of
dialogue is there
and i think the tunisian know how to do
that and i
stay confident that this is what's going
to happen it's
a national dialogue again the national
dialogue on this particular occasion if
and when it does happen
really does need to solve the problem of
forming the constitutional court
had the constitutional court been up and
running
perhaps we wouldn't be in this situation
right now
exactly first of all the uh article arie
of the tunisian constitution you know it
has
a legal lack which is actually the
establishment uh and the necessity of to
establish a constitutional court which
which didn't happen for the seven years
after the adoption of the constitution
so when an article in the constitution
is legally not complete
it cannot be triggered politically and
this is what i think
and this is my opinion that the
president should not have triggered
that article because it's not complete
legally yet by the establishment of the
constituent court
constitutional court is important to be
established is within the framework
of check and balances of democracy and
if you look at the article 80
it's all about checking balances
unfortunately the constitutional court
is not there yet which
i think is a priority in the political
process
of tunisia so indeed when you look at
tunisia
in 2021 it has an incredibly large young
population estimated at around about 30
percent
um they need to be engaged because they
have been the ones that have been
demonstrating they have been the ones
calling for
the government to fall they have been
the ones calling for change
exactly the social movement is comprised
majorly from young people in tunisia the
the challenge is that the political
instability
is also one of the criteria's on the
lack of
inclusion of young people into the
political system and political
institutions of tunisia
you look at an average of one government
every year ten governments
we have seen since the uh since 2011
and if you look at the numbers perhaps
in five percent
less than five percent are actually
people in the parliament who are
under the age of 35. what that created
also
is the mistrust from young people on the
democratic political systems so they
don't trust it so there is a lot of work
from both sides first
we need these uh political parties to be
including young people and give them
space to be expressing their
opinions about the political process on
the other side we need to build trust
among young people
for them to be able to trust the
democratic political process in tunisia
indeed the executive director and
co-founder of the nordic center for
conflict transformation
thanks for joining us are here on al
jazeera thank you